mr. Billy Bush is the former co-host of
the Today Show he was also on that other
show you know what happened Billy Bush
[Applause]
Kathy Griffin on last week I feel like
this is this is my month to rehabilitate
people who should not have been made to
go away this country I'd like to get
back to normal as we know you were you
know the guy in the bus with the
president when he said those nasty
things about grabbing [ __ ] first let's
just ask how we you would have handled
it differently now that you look I can
look back I probably would have just
changed the topic I mean I spent a lot
of time with Trump back then because I
didn't realize that that you Trump you
were a DX I was the entertainment
correspondent for NBC and he was the
cash cow he was the cash cow he was
pulling 20 million viewers a week or
something so I'm with him two three
times a week you had to kiss his ass
yeah I eat sort of I mean you sort of
meet them where they are or you can
interrupt him and then you know how
volatile he is right so he'd be like I
ate Billy Bush she's done moving on
Entertainment Tonight only forget Billy
Bush she's and then I have to explain
why I lost the right Trump the big fish
right so okay so and I'm sure everybody
says this to you but it is weird that he
kept his job and you lost yours little
irony yeah and how has that made you
feel the last year and a half yeah I'm
sure there was a period of bitterness
yeah oh yeah it's definitely it's in the
beginning you know it's it's let it it's
chaos right it's you got order in your
life and then all of a sudden in an
instant you have chaos right and you
don't know what end is up and there's
paparazzi all over the place and you're
and you're wondering you're gonna be
okay am I done and my I don't know and
then you go into the the whole thing but
then you sort of come out oddly enough
the day the Trump walked into the Oval
Office was the day that I walked into a
self-help retreat in Northern California
to sort of get back on my feet it's
called the Hoffman process I go up there
and I'm seven days off the grid I'm like
the guy from Ohio there who knew too
little
you know no phones no nothing and and
that was the beginning of just getting
over it look I mean if things happen to
people all in all my life
is pretty good I got right I got great
kids I got a I got a great family and
life is random bad bad things happen to
good people good things happen to bad
people yeah it's like people like me or
atheist how about you did it make you
lose your faith bill I thought you'd
like this I'm donating the eight hundred
and fifty dollars I get to appear here
to the church in Los Angeles just casaya
I thought you know external events you
can't control right right a whole bar
self-help work you can't control what
happens you can only control how you
react to it how you handle it and it
took me a while but then I said wait a
minute hold on things are pretty good
get back on your feet and I took my
daughter to Japan and she's 13 years old
obsessed with Japanese culture we went
there for 10 days I got a trip planned
with my with my middle daughter I'm
doing a little time you know things like
that that it's just well you ever wonder
what happens to you if like everything
went away the big career the big show
HBO the whole thing what does it happen
oh it's it's flashed before my eyes man
[Laughter]
I asked you about a few things about
Donna cuz you obviously do know him
better than most I did first of all did
he have a type like you know like in the
fire and fury book Michael Wolfe says
you know like his whole life was based
around chasing women like Bill Clinton I
mean I saw him on camera here and there
but I did host you know for Miss USA
pageants and for Universe pageants for
NBC at the time and you know he's yeah
he's definitely a you know he would come
backstage all the reports you've heard
of you know arriving backstage and
reviewing the guard like you know kim
jong on refused the military he comes
back with the with the tie that's too
long past the belt and their overcoats
and yeah but I think we all we know
about Donald Trump right we know who the
guy
well the story that I love that I think
is so indicative is when you called him
on the ratings once you said because the
apprentice was like number 30 and he was
saying it's number one well he's been
saying number one forever right and
finally I'd had enough I said wait I
don't hold it wait a minute you haven't
been number one for like five years so
four years whatever it is not in any
category not in any demo he goes well
did you see last Thursday last Thursday
18 to 49 whatever last five minutes or
whatever I you know no I don't know that
stat no I can so he's like I told you
and then later after when the cameras
are off when the cameras are off he says
he goes Billy look look you just tell
them and they believe it that's it you
just tell them and they believe that's
they just do as I said
uh-huh okay so where we are and so from
that point forward X is how natural it
was number one we were number two but
the fact that he can do that to America
now and that because that's exactly what
he does all the time he just says it and
they believe it yeah people do he never
said he was sorry to you right I mean he
never said they sorry the phone rang
yeah well he didn't do it I mean in
fairness he didn't you know and did leak
the tape but I didn't want him to call I
don't want to talk about this I haven't
spoken to him in four years I have to
ask one more thing did you actually give
him the Tic Tac when he asked for the
Tic Tac because I always thought that
your Tic Tacs right I always thought the
Tic Tac was sort of like their like a
Columbo episode that was the little
detail that that showed that he wasn't
this wasn't just locker room talk he was
really gonna do it across why else do
you need the Tic Tac know if you're not
gonna kiss somebody why Billy give me
attacked thirty years ago I kissed a lot
of s but that's where I drew the line
no ticked at all so I did not give him
the title did not give him I draw the
line glad to a foul got out
no tic-tac